I give Salam to my people in Bangladesh
Salam to the people of Marrakech
Salam to the Lions in Palestine Salam to
the bleep Salam aleikum Italy better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends welcome to another video on my
channel hope you guys are doing shall
our brothers and sisters may Allah bless
you guys
today's topic is quite heated quite
controversial some people are going to
be thinking what's going on so we're
gonna do three about sisters we're going
to talk about our take on shares what do
you think about she's actually very
needy topic very you know talking that
needs to be discussed you talk what did
you take her she else cuz we've had a
lot of discussions debates with them so
a lot of people have this perception and
perceive that you have this in a hate
towards them as this general mass is
this really it well first and foremost I
would say that it's important to
differentiate between a religion as
followers okay or sect and followers and
so people shouldn't take anything I say
personally that I talk when I talk about
a particular religious doctrine for
example like who talk about Christianity
or atheism or any other ISM right we're
talking about the doctrine yes you're
not necessarily intending the followers
with that so yeah I've done a lot of
debates I've done three formal debate
like two or three formal debates with
with she eyes which is aren't watching
on my channel and stuff like that and
what I've tried to highlight I've tried
to highlight some of the similarities
and differences between shares I've got
I've got a whole video on there so
people can watch that they want I think
it's important to get the elephant out
of the room that's why I that's why I do
it
so I think it's important to get the
elephant out of the room some people
have different approaches to coexistence
and cooperation yeah because at the end
of the day we're not in this world to
try and kill each other or fight that's
not our intention and that's not what
we're trying to do we're not trying to
be at odds with people so now we're not
trying to be odds that's if people think
that of us then that's just the wrong
understanding you know we're not trying
to be our odds of anyone but what we are
trying to do is we're trying to get the
elephant out of the room by speaking
about those controversial topics which
sometimes can be neglected
or feared by some some people some
people don't want to speak about she
guising because they think well if I'm a
Sunni I speak about Cher's him I'm
creating a controversy but from what
honestly from my experience I've found
that by speaking with she eyes well lie
and this is a true story and she eyes
have become much more receptive to me
that as a general mess I was in the gym
yesterday as you can see I'm in I'm in
good shape
[Laughter]
thousand a gym yesterday and and one guy
came and usually said I mean the guy was
in the gym and he said it's the first
time I've seen it's the first time he
saw me what's her name and he told me
his name in whatever and he said you
know I'm a Shia by himself because I'm a
shy boy this is exactly said he goes I
see what you're doing out there was some
of your videos and he says that I
believe it's quite positive what you're
doing
I've been getting this it's quite ironic
in a sense because I'm once again I'm
opposing a lot of the ideas of she isin
but because I'm not doing it with an
intention to try and humiliate the
audience just lay people I'm not trying
to hurt anyone's feelings I'm just
trying to speak the truth why I perceive
as a truth right yeah a lot of she has
have come and showed I would say their
support and respect to me so I think
it's foolish and I think naive to
actually think that just because we're
talking about say Christianity or
atheism or secularism that were against
secularists or atheists or Christians or
we don't dislike them look I mean some
some the Quran says about them this is a
beautiful thing about two words
lazy Susa where which means they are not
all the same just like and the same
thing is meant with the Sunnis as well
yeah
Sunnis everybody no one is the same we
can't generalize there are some people
which are bad and some people which are
good really good way to experience
person for myself as well like I don't
have like a dislike or like for example
and this is actually funny because I was
I was just telling you because I was in
Westfield and yeah and I saw the sister
and this was where the Prophet did was a
prophet worker and there was another
Samana sister yeah okay so she she
sure so I went there and I could see and
I could sales cuz she was trying to
express to ya me that something that I
did that she said to share community as
a whole yet cuz I don't I don't usually
drove into such stuff yeah
yeah shoes that you know when you
confronted Britt first and then this
issue you do talk here and you said I
know the shears do that here and
personally even before she said that I
acknowledged that the way I said it was
a bit rude because she has to well I
meant that by that was that basically
I'm assuming we don't do talk here she
owes new takea yeah so I did apologize
if someone's watching that because it
did come across rude and the reason I'm
saying that I'm not apologizing to
sugarcoat it for you if I believed
something I believe it straight and I'll
tell you what I believe we have our
differences it's simple here however
yeah I did say that to her and one thing
that I need to emphasize on what you
said as well is that we're not here to
insult so for example there are some
people who do videos and they instantly
outright these swearing and they
insulted in you guys in like this like
that and then it makes you wonder how do
you expect the person opposite you to
understand and come to common terms or
even if there's no common terms to
discuss the matter in a civil way when
you're insulting another person so I
personally upstate from that I've seen
you that you don't go down the route of
actually just in sorting them out Reggie
I'm trying to say yeah but okay I get
that you know just add to the point I
think you make a good point because what
you're saying is that basically
something like these are to be honest
review what we would call foreign
matters anyways yeah so you could you
could kind of the different ways that
scholars have done it in the past but
there are different categorizations for
example some say a fool and for raw but
the way even Tamiya but it was
interesting he said that you have mailed
me at and family yet so Emily Ed's are
those things in the Dean that you
implement yeah so for example flip check
for us is jurisprudence law when when
approaching are talking to a CI I never
really talk about things that are Populi
spoken about I've never once made a had
a discussion about motor which is
something which is I believe caricatured
and unfairly Annie talk it spoken about
as if it's the centerpiece of the
difference between shares it's amazing
it's not the centerpiece of difference
in terms of difference that's that goes
way on the world list they talk about
once again the the the ready that that's
the twelfth mercy and once again the
fact is
hiding in the surf dab is like a place
in Iraq and you know and they make fun
of them and on that basis say how could
he be in that place and we've been there
he isn't dead I'm not saying there's no
legitimacy in the in the discussion but
I'm saying that this is low and low on
the list of priorities when we're
talking to she eyes so I never speak
about those things for very
intentionally because these are or you'd
call Amelie yet they come as a result of
believing the premises so in the in the
discussions I've had with Shia as I've
always just wanted to speak about what
the Isola what the foundations of
difference are and I've narrowed it down
to three just quickly to go through them
one of them is the idea of Amana okay
which I believe is the most important
one of all of them obviously as
certainly Muslims we believe in the five
pillars of Islam of the hadith of boonie
Islam Allah hamsa the hadith of M no
armor the five pillars everyone knows
the five pillars and we believe in six
pillars of Eman and the six pillars of a
man has to believe in Allah and to in
Bellaire molarity in his angels
koutoubia and his books all those holy
here and his a and his prophets well yo
Malaya and the last day and the father
of the pre there was written yeah now
the argument I was put forward to them
is that these fundamental things are
always I mean they're so fundamental
that they are repeated very often in the
Quran not only just mentioned once but
oft repeated things because they're the
centerpiece of the religion right so I
will say to them if Imam is as important
as say for example prophethood surely it
should be mentioned in the Quran and
that's where we talk and discuss a
little and they try and bring their the
Leal's
is it mentioned or is it not mentioned
that's where my discussions have gone of
course we don't have the time to talk
about this here and now but that's what
I've always given them a chance to kind
of represent themselves I don't feel
like it's fair for me even now to
present a whole case for it
people can refer to the arguments
because it's a debate with two sides and
if people can see what's happened yeah
but that's where the I always say well
you've got the six pillars of a man of
armor his hadith which are all which
there's the hadith of like all the most
Sunni Muslims agree upon which are all
to be found the Quran but this idea of
ammama
if it was so central if we had to
believe that there were 12 Imams all of
which
infallible all of which had to be
followed just like prophets are followed
in fact all of those twelve amends to
she eyes are more important than all of
the prophets except for prophet muhammad
they're that important so ali bin abu
talib for she I is more important than
Jesus Christ is more important than
Abraham he's more important than Moses
there is differences but that element is
there yes fasting oh this is there so if
the mommy ever who said if there was a
big thing even in the Sunnis life it
would play a role exactly yeah yeah if
it's not Ron yeah if it was so important
we would say we would argue then it
should be in the Quran or at least it
should be in sometimes we can even go
further than that say hadith which is
agreed upon by Sunnis and Shiites
absolutely what we don't find that's the
difference but the other two who should
don't have time to talk about now is the
Sahaba the stance on the Sahaba so
obviously in the Quran Allah says that
Allah so Allah says he's Raja Lohan was
cool table dear Allah says he is pleased
with them and we would say that they
would a lot of shiz and all of them but
they reject that premise completely that
these people they are post-dated yeah my
for example no Quran chapter 9 verse 100
yeah it says very clearly that Allah is
pleased with the Muhajiroun
and the answer he's pleased with those
who have come the to emigrate to Medina
yeah and the ants are the helpers and
the other Sahaba obviously she said to
me person she said look I don't because
I don't curse her companions yeah yeah
yeah she said it goes I know if she does
they don't even know until you say that
but as far as I know a lot of [ __ ] for
example youngsters yes they don't know
and generate that couse I love them
don't they they just like look we don't
know we don't you know so there is those
are out there is well as well absolutely
and I think that's a really important
point to stress that this is a point
really important to stress that not oh
she eyes are the same and to be
completely fair to them I have looked at
some of them are large a sum of their
even they're big scholars and they say
that when because some of them do curse
yeah don't do it in public especially in
areas where there's where there's
division between Sunni and Shiite so
that's that's two things the third thing
is this
yeah we would say that if you implement
you know you could potentially nullify
your a men would say especially if you
do it to the mother of the believers and
stuff like that could nullify all of us
lamb because it goes against the verses
of the Quran it goes against the Quran
make clear verses right do they
understand because imagine someone go
into their mom and accuse them of
something or be their their father's
companions who die hard you know
battled with their father and imagine
somehow coming and saying oh your dad's
friends who did this - yeah they are all
your mothers and I'm sure that's what a
lot of them don't do it because they
understand and you know they think you
know what
to be totally honest with you my my
interaction of this year has been quite
positive like I'll be totally honest
with you like I go I've been invited to
them like Institute's to do debates
obviously it's spoken to some of them
are spoken to their people of knowledge
a lot of their people of knowledge and
even though I disagree with them
vehemently I mean on doctrinal issues
right a mama being one of them for
example yeah which was spoken about in
depth or on the states of preservation
for iron being another one that's how
being assert and even though I disagree
with them fundamentally you want these
issues I think what my interaction with
shares has been really positive because
they've respected the fact that I'm
willing to engage them on those
differences and respect them and treat
them with with respect
sometimes I've slipped up on that I mean
no one's perfect that's happened yeah
yeah yeah for sure but yeah I mean I
think that the main thing here is that
we need to kind of promote that we're
living in the West and what's happening
in the Middle East like for example in
Iraq and in Syria this kind of mentality
shouldn't be kind of we don't want that
to ever come here this is in a sense
we're both Akal yet were both minorities
and in the West when we do our work for
example me and you I don't when we do
our work when you when you're
confronting the Islamophobes and stuff
that benefits Shiites and Sunnis it
doesn't just benefit some news when we
do our work that benefits both of us and
so on points of agreement I don't see
that there's a reason for us not to kind
of to kind of see that as a for example
we've got a united with the united enemy
we have a common enemy you know we're
not saying
go into now unite upon on what we
consider forces we're not saying this
but what we're saying is that we have a
common enemy and even if we do for
example we have to be real with us off
come on yeah even if we do have some
kind of a dislike or a hatred it's to
the action because come on anyone if I
swore at your mom and and come on come
let's be real here
yeah if I swore at your mom you ever it
may be yeah yeah if somebody's swear I'm
not gonna be like oh come on let's be
real here we'd have to say you know what
I hate I hate what you're doing you know
you clear on this mess in here nobody's
gonna tolerate this well like my dear
brother and sister I wish at home anyone
comes in based forget this forget it's
not any mom just mentioning your mom you
know your mom oh yeah right well put it
this way as if someone spoke about fall
tomorrow yeah and well I've come into
that you have comments at one like this
I want a mission like my before I came
to the down my name's to earlier I look
I went to the background in hand no
matter been cut up and I've miss you on
them and Ali was just the character that
I just loved as much a son of Abu Bakr
and Omar and all the companions yeah but
I just specifically like and I did not
say to myself okay I need to become a
Shia to love alien a debate of course no
well I would love them do you love them
that's a fundamental all that we do if
you don't you can't be exact you can't
be almost exactly we love them as much
as you do but we just say we don't have
to belong to a certain group to show
that affection love towards them and one
thing that was really profound cuz when
I'm speaking to this is that the reason
I'll emphasize it because she was so
caught up and she she felt really hurt I
said to her sister do you really believe
in so let me ask you this question
you're walking down the road you see a
sister or brother in trouble are you
gonna say even if we saw complete a
Christian or a Jew exactly an atheist
anybody in trouble our religion tells us
to get involved I mean come on can I
tell you why you will be Eddie the poet
says if whoever sees something evil let
him change it with his hand and the
restarts are fabulous any if you can't
do it the name do with this tongue and
if you can't deny at least have the hate
in his heart
that's Obama says I don't know says
anyone I don't this is the reason we did
this video is just to make it understand
we have our differences so whenever the
Commission
call and say let's hold hand and when
the same it's just to understand that
where we're coming from what we're doing
it's the same with for you guys you
disagree with us anew emphasizing you
talk about there and that's what we do
so we want to understand that there is
not this in a form of animosity - I'm
trying to see and that's why I was the
infamous model I think was actually I
think it's very fruitful one I think
that you know this war I've learned from
the kind of last year or ever as I've
been doing by engaging the she is that
really to be honest with that there has
been this kind of taboo in talking about
it completely and I think that is the
wrong approach but it's all about how
you do it exactly you can have you can
have your belief wherever your belief is
right it's about how you engage with
someone who differs with you so that's
the key that's so that's so key and you
know having wisdom because that's what
is that I'm sure love share brother this
isn't watching this TV you know one look
we don't have a problem with the
disagreements and the discussions
whenever the issue is when the animosity
and the insults and this is behavior
that we are totally against it's not the
way to go about how can I go and give
let's suppose our share buffers is all
wrong yeah there's things that would
leave the room action yet oh of course
imagine imagine I start off with saying
firstly I want to say you know you you
are like this and like that and like
that
now let's talk about why you should
become a suddenly it's not gonna work
you know and it's not gonna be able to
Cristiano start sweating he's gonna say
I don't want to know you about your toe
heat look wait look at your behavior so
that's why yeah I mean I would one more
thing is I would say that you know from
my perspective especially youth I found
that some people have been very angry
and rightfully so I would say rightfully
so because the Companions get curse
especially by some very extreme yes just
like we have extremist groups in chasm
we have extremist groups I will say calm
down because the thing is that happens
everywhere people are people are
disrespecting the performance analyzer
them who is more important to us than as
a hub on bail and people are even
disrespecting Allah subhana WA Ta'ala so
if you can tolerate their disrespect to
those respective people's you should
sometimes we get really upset when we
should or ally around whoever may be and
Allah Allah or a daily basis and
can you imagine somebody in sultan
hassan ali and you have a bigger problem
than allah or someone's it's also an
Ummah Democrat Arbuckle and Allah but we
have to rectify because the main
fundamental thing is we worship none
other than Allah and our key element and
our hate should be and what I mean here
I'm not talking about do some physical
hating the action that's being done if
someone is insulting Allah you know many
ways maybe that's for another topic if
you watch this I would encourage
everyone to share this with your friends
and family especially our share Bob's
and sisters share this with your friends
and family in shower and hope we can
come to a common understanding
you shall and even if we don't we can
agree thank you much Barack refika
ceremony come when I mentor a better
care to from another video from me and
baba howmany job